oui en france n'est pas de droite mais
alors pourquoi est ce que les verts et
le ps ont fait des scores aussi minable
parce que parce que n'ont pas su créer
un programme ils n'ont pas su incarner
sa part une équipe françois mitterrand
était un homme d'exception mais il était
entouré de genre moi mise à part tout à
fait exceptionnelle et et il était assez
mégalomane pour ne pas craindre d'être
entouré de gens de talent ouais d'accord
à le cas de tout le monde et et qui est
aussi d'ailleurs le cadre de mélenchon
qui est entouré de l'an talent et qui ne
le crains pas donc la gauche
gouvernement accumule je peux faire des
petites phrases inutiles mais il n'y a
rien de plus médiocre que d'avoir peur
de gens qui sont moins médiocre que
soient ses essais mortel est mortelle
dans les familles c'est mortel dans les
entreprises c'est mortel dans les
organisations politiques est-ce que là
il ya une refondation possible en tout
cas ce que vous êtes bon balle au ps est
arrivé au bout maintenant il faut
réinventer solder les comptes
peut-être faire un livre de raison du ps
mais il faut recommencer le dernier mais
il faut recommencer il faut pour
commencer à la base la base c'est faire
des colloques des réflexion
programmatique avait été tout le monde à
débattre et au bout d'un an deux ont
brillé sur le temps ils ont cinq ans
devant eux vous vous dites vous que la
france est à gauche c'est la victoire
d'emmanuel mâcon qui vous fait dire ça
les thèmes vous l'avez dit vous-même les
thèmes pouvoir d'achat écologie
protection protection à tout prix y
compris la sécurité tout ça c'est des
thèmes de gauche c'est évidemment des
thèmes du gauche
c'est évident que la gauche aurait dû
être majoritaire
politiquement alors et pourtant vous
avez un président de répliques que vous
connaissez bien qui a pris deux premiers
ministres qui viennent de la droite et
peut-être éventuellement un nouveau être
on peut dire qu'il a pris deux premiers
le droit tâche que comme il était en
même temps il est un peu plus à gauche
que c'était lui là c'était lui le la
jambe gauche c'était manuellement
si vous aviez une idée de premier
ministre aujourd'hui
en tête ce ne serait pas à vous que je
les confie ray et une femme mais ce
serait bien ce serait pas à vous que
j'en parle
[Musique]